The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK,
so last time we
talked about
non-linear dynamics.
We drew phase plots.
We talked about
basins of attraction.
We talked about fixed points.
And we hinted at control, and
I tried to motivate control
not as some nice matrix
manipulation of equations,
but actually by thinking
about phase plots and saying,
you're going to move that
phase plot a little bit.
You're going to
reshape it in order
to bend the system
to your will right--
but just a little bend.
You're only allowed a little
building in this class.
OK, so today we're going
to make good on that idea,
but we're going to do it on an
even simpler system first, just
today.
We're going to do it on the
double integrator, which
is q double dot equals u--
because here I can do everything
analytically on the board.
If you want a physical
interpretation of that--
which I always like--
you can think of this
as a brick of unit mass
on ice, where you provide
as a control input
a force, like this.
[INAUDIBLE] force equals
u, and there's no friction,
and mass equals 1.
What we're going to try to do
with this double integrator is
roughly, we're going to
try to drive it to some--
to the origin.
We're going to try to
drive it to zero position--
I guess that's negative
x in this picture--
and with 0 velocity.
It turns out there's
lots of ways to do that.
And the goal here is to
make you think about ways
to do that that involve
invoking optimality,
because that's going to be
our computational crutch
for the rest of the term.
OK.
I've been trying
to bring the tools
from the different
disciplines all together.
So let me start by doing
just a quick pole placement
analysis, for those of you
that don't think about poles
and linear systems that much.
So if I want to write the--
a state space form
this equation-- again,
I've always tried to use q
just to be my coordinates,
and I'll use x to
be my state vector.
So a state space form of this
is going to use vector x to be,
in this case, q and q dot.
And that dynamics there is
the simplest state space
form you're going to see, but
a state space linear equation
will have the form Ax plus Bu.
In our case, it's going to be
the trivial 0,1' 0, 0; and x
plus 0, 1 times u.
OK, it's not going to
get easier than that,
but we're going
to use that form,
because that's going to help.
OK, our goal now is to design u.
We want to come up with
a control action u--
which you can think of as
being a force on the brick,
let's say--
which drives the system to 0.
So in general, our goal is
to design some feedback law--
I use pi for my
control policies--
which is a function of x.
Let's start by doing
the linear thing.
Let's start with
considering [INAUDIBLE]
of the form of negative
kx, where k is a matrix.
Well, actually, what
is k in this case?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: 1 by 2, right?
So it's going to be k1, k2
times x, which is my q, q dot--
equivalent of saying
negative k1q minus k2 q dot.
So many of you
will recognize this
as a proportional
derivative controller form.
OK, so if I take this
u equals negative x
and I start thinking about
what that-- if I change k,
what happens to
my control system?
That's easy to do
in linear systems.
So if I stick that gain
matrix in, then what I get
is a closed loop system,
which is A minus--
sorry-- minus Bk x, which
is just the system 0, 1;
negative k1, negative k2; x.
OK, and if you've had a class
on differential equations,
you know how to solve that.
The solution uses the
eigenvalues of the system.
You can quickly take the
eigenvalues of that matrix.
Characteristic equation out to
be k squared minus 4k1 over 2,
with eigenvectors--
v1 is this, v2 is this.
That's just the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of this matrix.
So what are the conditions
on the eigenvalues
to make sure the
system's stable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: [INAUDIBLE]
both negative.
Potentially, we care about
whether the system has any
oscillations or not, which
manifest themselves and whether
that's--
whether the thing's complex--
[INAUDIBLE] complex eigenvalues.
This is all things you've
seen in plenty of classes,
but the only way it's
going to be complex
is if this thing
goes negative, right?
OK.
So we want a couple of things.
We want both of them to be--
both of these to be less than 0,
which we can get pretty easily.
And we want k2 squared
to be bigger than 4k1.
k2 squared is bigger than 4k1--
then the system is
actually overdamped.
If it equals 4k1, it's
critically damped.
And it's underdamped
if it's less than 4k1.
For stability, we want lambda
1 and 2 to be less than 0
for stability.
OK, so just to connect this to
the phase plots we were talking
about yesterday, you've seen--
you might have seen phase
plots first in this context,
in the linear systems. context .
The reason to do this
eigenvalue decomposition
is that you have these beautiful
graphical interpretations
of the solutions to the system.
Let's choose a particular case.
What did I pick?
So let's say k1 is 1.
That means I'm going
to want to think
about an overdamped system.
I want k2 to be at
least greater than 2.
So I'm going to
choose k2 equals 4.
If I do that, then
my eigenvalues
work out to be negative 4
plus or minus 16 minus 4
over 2, which is negative 2 plus
or minus the square root of 3.
Square root of 3 is about 1.75.
So I get negative
0.25 and negative 3.75
for my eigenvalues.
OK.
And the eigenvectors are
going to be just this form.
So what that allows me to do
is make my same state space
plots we were making yesterday
where now I have q and q dot.
And my first eigenvector is
going to be 1, negative 0.25.
I'll use these as quarters.
So I go minus 0.25
[INAUDIBLE] 1 here,
so I get a line that
looks like this.
That's v1.
And I get a line that goes
almost 1, negative 4--
so a little bit under that here.
v2 is over here.
OK.
And the eigenvalues
on this-- if you've
seen these plots before,
we typically [INAUDIBLE]
They're both negative,
so we're going
to draw an arrow like this.
Systems-- initial conditions
that start on this
will just get smaller.
Initial conditions that start
on this will also get smaller,
but they can actually get
smaller a lot quicker.
Just to say a few
of the subtleties,
so I an overdamp
system so I don't
have repeated eigenvalues.
I chose a overdamped system
so I don't have oscillations,
because I can make
the same plots.
But for the overdamped
system, this
is a great way to
think about things.
When I don't have repeated
eigenvalues, the--
any initial condition
of the system
can be written as a
linear combination.
That means that, when
the system doesn't
have repeated eigenvalues, the
eigenvectors span the space.
Any initial conditions can be
written as a linear combination
of the two eigenvalues.
And the dynamics from
this point are just
the exponential
dynamics on the--
of the two components.
I don't know.
Tell me if you want me to
say that again in a more--
it's not really the focus,
but if you understand that,
you got the whole thing here.
So what it means is you could
take any initial condition-- it
turns out, any initial condition
when I have eigen vectors which
span the space.
I'm guaranteed to have that,
if I have unique eigenvalues.
Then I can write this as a
combination of these vectors.
I've got one component like this
and one component like this.
This initial condition--
if I say this is x0--
so I can say x0 is alpha 1
times v1 plus alpha 2 times v2.
We know that initial conditions
that are just on the line v1
go e to the negative lambda--
or e to the lambda t
v1, so the whole system
goes alpha 1 e to the
negative lamb-- oh, sorry.
I've got negative eigenvalues--
to the lambda t v1 plus alpha 2
e to the lambda 2 t v2.
That's the great thing about
all these linear systems.
So what that means is, if
I've drawn the eigenvectors,
then I know exactly the entire
phase plot of the system.
So we're connecting
back to the pendulum.
I went through in all
the different places.
I thought about what
the contributions
were and mapped it out.
Here I don't have to do that.
I know that this system is
going to-- the component--
the space that has--
in this eigenvalue
is going to decay
quickly towards 0.
And it's going to decay
faster than this one, which
means an initial condition like
this is going to go like this.
I should have used one of my
many other colors to do that.
Looks like a blue--
so trajectories from
that initial condition
are going to do that.
And trajectories from
this initial condition
are going to-- what
are they going to do,
if I start over here?
They're going to go mostly
down, and eventually we
think it's stable, so it's
going to get to the origin.
I can even do my
filled in circle there.
When are they going to start
bending towards the origin?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Later-- they
have to pass this before--
they have to pass that and
get the negative velocities
before they can hook back in.
So the trajectories look
like this, and go in.
Yeah?
And likewise, so all
these trajectories--
you can map out the entire
phase portrait of the space
pretty quickly just by
understanding the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
Same thing's true over here.
OK, so there's another example
of a phase plot that we have.
In the linear systems,
it works out to be clean.
You can just do these
eigenvalues, eigenvectors.
OK, now, control-- we're
allowed to change k1 and k2.
Changing k1 and k2 is going
to change the phase portrait.
It's going to change
those vectors.
I want to change them to
make it do whatever I want.
The first discussion is, what
do we want to make it do?
Maybe even before that,
I should observe that,
without thinking about
optimality at all,
it would be easy to
stop here, because I--
if I look at this carefully,
as long as I choose k squared--
k2 squared greater than 4, K1.
I know I'm going
to not oscillate.
And I can just
start driving k1--
and correspondingly, k2--
up as high as I like,
and make the system get to
the origin as fast as I want,
and it won't oscillate.
Why not just drive them
all the way to infinity?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: You can't--
don't have a motive to do that.
That's the first
unsatisfying thing--
absolutely.
Probably there's
some unmodeled thing.
Even if I did have a
motive that could do that,
there's probably
some unmodeled things
that I might excite, and cause
bad things to happen anyways.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: You could melt
the ice and it'll break.
That's right.
I guess I could
have said wheels,
and then maybe they'd
melt the tires.
OK.
And you can see
that here, actually.
Remember?
What is the unactuated phase
plot of the system look like?
I can just draw that.
If u was just uniformally
0, if k1 and k2 were 0,
what would the phase
have looked like there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: It
would have just been
x dot equals A of x,
where A is this guy.
So it wouldn't have
been as interesting.
Every point would have just
had a vector like this.
It would have been a little
bigger with bigger velocities,
but it's just--
it would just be
a flow like that,
which I hope is what
you'd expect it to do,
since it's an integrator.
Things are just going to--
off into the ether.
OK.
So if I consider--
I started with this, and
I'm getting out things that
look like this, I'm already--
in my unitless cartoon
here, it's sort of already
looks like I'm using a lot of
torque to do what I'm doing.
I'm using a lot of force.
I'm really
significantly changing
those dynamics in order
to bend this thing
to come around like that.
That's OK, but we can do better.
So today I want to
use this system, which
I think it's quite easy to
have strong intuition for,
to start designing optimal
feedback controllers.
So let's address the we
don't have infinite torque
problem first.
One more comment on this--
I didn't actually
call them poles--
there's a pole placement
version of this too.
It's exactly the same thing.
If you were to
draw a root locus,
what would the system look like?
The typical root
locus would be you're
multiplying the entire
feedback by some linear term.
You're not scaling them
in some squared law,
so what you get is, for
very small feedback gains,
you get oscillations.
As you crank it up, the poles
connect in the left half plane,
and then they separate.
And as I keep turning
up my gains, one of them
creeps towards the origin.
The other one goes off
really far to infinity.
So just those of you think
about poles and zeros,
this is exactly the
same way to say that.
I didn't do a root locus because
I was changing two parameters,
but it all connects.
OK, so now, let's say I
have a hard constraint
on what u I can provide.
Let's just say that I have an
additional constraint that's,
let's say, the absolute value
of u has got to be less than 1.
Well, that changes
a lot of things.
My linear system analysis
is impoverished now.
If you want a graphical version
of what that's doing, that's--
my zero input looked like that.
I wanted to go like this
with my linear controller,
but maybe it's capped
at something like this.
OK, so what's that going
to do to your system?
If I just ran the policy
u is some saturation, say,
on negative kx, I took my same
feedback-- linear feedback
controller and I just said,
if it's greater than 1 it's 1;
if it's less than negative
1, it's negative 1,
I think you're still OK.
Trajectories are still
going to get to the origin.
They might take fairly
long routes to the origin.
You're not going
to lose stability
in this case because
of that, but it
starts to feel like,
man, I should really
be thinking about
those hard constraints
when I design my controller.
All right.
So how do we do that?
One way to do that
is optimal control.
It's not the only way to do it.
Let's formulate an
optimal control problem.
Let me sync up with my notes
so I don't go too far afield.
OK.
Let's say my goal in life is
to get to the origin as fast
as possible in minimum time.
But I'm subject to
this constraint.
So that's the famous
minimum time problem--
subject to that constraint.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes.
What do we want?
Both the position and
the velocity to be 0.
Turns out you need
this constraint for it
to be a well-posed problem.
If I didn't have constraints
on u, then, like I said,
I would just use as
much u as possible.
I would get there
infinitely fast,
and we haven't
learned a whole lot.
There are other ways to penalize
u or something like that,
but we're going to put a
hard constraint on it here.
OK, now, muster all your
intuition about bricks and ice
and tell me--
if I've got limited
force to give
and I want to get to the
origin as fast as possible,
what should I do?
AUDIENCE: Bang-bang.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Bang-bang.
Good.
He knows the answer.
What should I do?
People haven't thought about
it and don't know bang-bang is.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Right.
Right.
So if I want to get there
as fast as possible,
I'm going to hit
the accelerator,
go as fast as I can until
some critical point,
where I'm going
to hit the brakes.
And I'm going to skid
stop right into the goal.
There's nothing better
I can do than that.
We're going to prove
that, but I want
to see-- that's a fairly
complicated thing.
It's something you can guess
for the double integrator.
You can't guess for a
walking robot, for instance.
But we want to get that out
of some machinery that's
going to be more general
than double integrators.
OK, so the proposition
was bang-bang control.
You might hear
people casually say,
bang-bang control's
optimal, and that is--
if you have hard limits
on your actuators,
it's very common that
the best thing to do
is to be at those
limits all the time.
If that's the way you've
defined the problem,
bang-bang control solutions
are pretty ubiquitous.
They don't always work
that well in real robots,
because actuators don't
like to produce zero--
infinite force and then--
or max force and
then negative max
force within a single time step.
Good-- OK, so I think the
only subtle part about it
is figuring out when I
need to switch from hitting
the gas to hitting the brakes.
So let's see if we can
figure that out first.
I think a pretty
good way to do it
is to think about what
happens if you hit the brakes.
And then you want
to hit the brakes
and arrive directly at the goal.
There's only going to
be a handful of states
from which, if I was
going at some-- if I was
some position and some velocity
and I hit the brakes full now,
I'm going to land
exactly at the goal.
Let's see if we can figure
out that set of states first.
Let's think about the case
where q is greater than 0 first.
Just pick a side.
So in that case,
hitting the brakes--
is that positive
1 or negative 1?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Negative 1--
no, it's positive 1.
You almost got me.
If q is greater than
0, it's positive.
q is greater than 0--
then u is positive.
I want to be pushing
back in the direction
I'm already coming from,
so u is positive 1.
All right, so now, we're going
to have some math ahead of us.
See if we can integrate
this equation.
I can do that on
the board for you.
q dot of t--
I better get it right.
[LAUGHTER]
ut-- so in this case, it was 1--
plus q dot of 0.
I'll just make it a little bit
more [INAUDIBLE] This case,
it was 1, and q
double dot of t is--
sorry-- switch orders-- q0 plus
q dot 0 t plus 1/2 ut squared.
OK, I want to figure out--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Did I screw it up?
What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Thank you-- good.
Thank you.
OK, so let's figure out, if
u is 1, what trajectories
are going to get me so that q--
at some t final, qt
and q dot of t are 0--
simple enough--
little manipulation.
So it turns out I'm going
to solve for q0 and q dot 0.
So q dot 0--
looks like that's going
to be negative u of t.
It's a little bit
weird, my notation here.
I'm saying that the
initial conditions
are moving backwards.
The equations are simple enough.
I hope it's OK.
And q0 t had better be--
it turns out to
be 1/2 ut squared.
So q dot of t is negative ut.
Add those together.
q0 is going to be
1/2 ut squared.
If I solve for t-- solve out t--
in this case, u is 1 so t,
say, is just negative q dot.
So q of 0 is just 1/2--
let's keep that.
This is just 1 t
squared q dot 0 squared.
If I plot that, what I've
got in my state space--
q, q dot-- is a manifold of
solutions, which starts at 0.
And then I said that I did
this for u is positive.
And it goes like this.
This one's not a solution.
Where did I get that out?
And one of my
assumptions here when
I inverted t or something that
I-- that solution disappears.
You can't have negative time.
In fact, in my notes, I did it.
I solved for the other t,
which would have been better.
Sorry.
OK, so there's a line
of solutions here--
which, if I started this
q-- this is actually
the positive queue,
negative q velocities.
I hit the brakes.
I go coasting into the
stop at the origin.
Turns out, if I do-- if I think
about the negative q case,
I get a similar line--
similar curve.
[INAUDIBLE] quadratic
curve over here.
You know what-- let me be
a little bit more careful.
Let me make that one pink,
because this is the now u
is negative 1 case.
Good.
We figured out the
line of solutions
where, if I hit the brakes,
they get to the origin.
Harness your intuition again.
What do I do if I'm here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Right.
This was the stopping
all the way to the goal.
So pretty much, from anywhere
else, I want to accelerate.
So what does accelerating
look like when I'm here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's going
to put me going up.
And what happens is, any
time I'm below this curve,
I'm going to drive myself up.
I can't go backwards like that
and drive myself up, hit that,
and ride it in.
And if I'm above the
curve, what do I do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Have to
overshoot a little bit--
I can't bend down
more than this,
so I'm going to ride it
all the way over to here,
connect up to this
surface, and ride it in.
And it turns out, any time I'm
over here, the best thing to do
is to--
did I get my colors wrong?
Got my colors wrong--
let me fix that.
Sorry.
It's confusing.
This is the accelerate,
and then break.
And this is the break.
Let me just recolor it for you
to make it a little more clear.
Sorry about that.
So let's say I'm pink
over here, blue over here.
OK.
I want to be pink.
I want to decelerate
just like this
if I'm above it because I
want to take these curves that
are almost there.
If I've got extra
time, I'm going
to accelerate to the point
where I decelerate again, so
down here should be blue.
And then this is,
again, the case
where I decelerate as much as I
can until I take the pink line.
This was the u
equals negative 1,
and this was the u
equals positive 1.
OK.
Is that at all satisfying?
We can now connect this back
again to your phase plot
pictures.
We had our initial lines
that looked like this.
[INAUDIBLE] allowed to apply
a bounded amount of torque.
So the best thing I can
do, if I'm right here,
is I can warp this thing
down to the point where
I get right there.
And if I'm here,
I can warp it up
to push me here, and
then ride it down.
The hard part is actually
showing that that's optimal.
And the reason I'm going to go
through it is because it's-- it
forms the basis for all the
algorithms that are going to be
more general.
So let me show you
that that's optimal.
To do that, I need to
introduce our first optimality
ideas for the course.
Are people OK with the--
that picture?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
below the line.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: So tell me where.
Bottom right?
OK.
So this is the place
where, if I decelerate,
I get to the origin.
If I'm here, then I have
a little bit more velocity
in the same position.
So if I hit the brakes, I'm
not going to stop in time.
I don't quite
decelerate fast enough
to get here, because
there's limited torque,
so I just slip past it until my
chance to come in the other way
again.
The only separation
is that curve.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Everywhere
up here, you want to be--
top left you said?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Here, you're blue.
The same way, you want to
accelerate as much as you can,
because you want
to get to the place
where you have to
hit the brakes.
This is me.
I'm at some position.
I don't have enough
velocity that I
have to just hit
my brakes, so I'm
going to gun it until I'm
at the velocity where I just
have to hit my brakes,
and then ride it in.
Up here, I'm at the point
where I have too much velocity.
Even if I hit my
brakes, I'm still
going to overshoot
a little bit, which
means I'm going to have to--
and so you could
think of it as now--
the word brakes maybe flips
when you flip that cross across.
Maybe that's the right thing.
But the action I take
is only changing based
on that switching surface--
which, as you know,
will be a nightmare
for a lot of our reinforcement
learning algorithms.
This is a hard cusp.
So if you have a control system
that has a hard non-linearity
like this, which is--
I'm doing one thing here,
and I'm immediately,
at some discrete place,
doing a different thing--
that's a very non-linear event.
And it's hard to
get analytically
when you're doing
something more complicated
than a double
integrator, and it can
be hard to get computationally.
But we'll talk about
that when the time comes.
OK, so how the heck do I make an
optimality argument about this?
I want to introduce
Pontryagin's minimum principle.
OK.
This is going to be a load
of equations real quick,
and we're going
to tease them out.
In general, optimal control
problems are going to go--
are going to be formulated
by designing a cost function.
That cost function is
some scalar quantity
that I want to minimize.
I'm going to use the
symbols g of x you
as an instantaneous
cost function.
I'll use h of x to
mean final costs.
I'm going to show you what
this means in a second.
And I'm going to use J
of x to be a cost-to-go.
It's very important-- all
of these are scalars--
not vectors at all,
just a scalar quantity.
So a typical optimal
control problem
will be formulated as
something like h of x capital T
plus integral from 0 to T g of
x u dt, subject to x dot of t
is f of xu.
Let's say the dynamics
and x0 t is some--
let me it call it x0 here--
x0.
This is a general
cost function--
cost-to-go function form
for optimal control.
We're going to use it a lot.
There's just a couple of
things to note about it.
So just to get some
intuition, so g of xu--
that's things I'm penalizing
throughout the trajectory.
So maybe I want to do
small actions in general,
in which case, I could
put some term in here,
which penalizes
me for having a u.
I could put a u squared in
here or something like that.
Or maybe I want to
just worry about being
a long way from the origin.
Maybe I'll put an x squared in
here or something like this.
h is a final cost.
It's some function
that only penalizes
the final state of the system.
So maybe I don't care what I'm
doing for the first capital T
seconds, but at
time capital T, I
want to penalize it
for being away from 0--
x squared here or
something like that.
There's lots of different forms.
The only thing that's
really important
to note about this, the only
really restriction in the forms
that you can play
with, is that we
do tend to assume this
form, which is additive.
It's integrable-- integrates
some scalar cost g.
So I don't look at
multiplicative contributions
of--
from x at time 1 and x time
4 or something like that.
I'm only looking at
additive cost functions.
Assuming that form--
that additive cost form
will make all the
derivations work, roughly.
OK, so for the minimum time
problem, what is that form?
You could formulate it a
couple of different ways.
In this case, I could actually
have g of xu equals 1,
and have capital T
defined as the time,
and have h of x equal 0.
That's a perfectly reasonable
optimal control formulation.
So it certainly fits in this
general optimal control form.
OK, so now we need
to know how to--
we've got this guess.
I'm going to leave that
hard-earned picture up there.
I like this one too, but--
let me just say what
Pontryagin's minimum principle
is first, and then we'll
make sure it makes sense.
So for this general form, J
of x is h of xT plus integral
from 0 to T g x,
u dt, subject to--
and I'm going to try to be
very careful about writing
these all every time.
Let's assume for-- to begin
with, capital T is fixed,
just a parameter somebody chose.
Let's say u is
bounded to some set u.
In our problem right now, it
was negative 1 to 1, right?
The minimum principle
goes like this.
We're going to define this
new auxiliary function,
the Hamiltonian, capital H. If I
have found some optimal control
solution--
I'll think of it in
terms of-- the solution
right now in terms of
a trajectory, which
is some sequence x
star of t, u star of t.
Then it must satisfy the
following conditions.
First of all, we know it must
satisfy f of x star u star.
That was already one
of our conditions.
And it has to satisfy the--
OK.
There's a significantly
less trivial one,
which is that p dot of t has got
to equal to negative partial h,
partial x evaluated
at x star, u star, p--
which, if h is what
I had up there,
works out to be
partial g, partial x,
plus partial f, partial x.
Transpose p.
And this auxillary
variable that we
had has to be the gradient of
partial h evaluated x star t.
One last condition--
this is 1, 2, 3.
u star t had better
be the argmin
over u of h of x star, u, p.
OK.
Sorry.
Cut that out.
We're going to make
sense of it now.
OK, before we derive it--
and I'll just do a sketch
of the derivation--
but before we derive
it, let's just
think about the implications.
First of all, this says the
optimal control trajectory must
satisfy, which means it's
a necessary condition
for optimality.
If I found some
optimal trajectory x
star, u star, some trajectory
x, u, I can verify that--
a necessary condition is that
all these things are hold,
but that's actually not
a sufficient condition
in general.
For linear systems
that are convex--
linear dynamics that are
convex and the cost function,
it turns out it's OK,
but in general, it's
not always sufficient.
And it says that, if I take my
x and I integrate it forward
in time, solving x by
integrating my dynamics
forward, and then I take
this other function--
this new set of variables p,
which happens to have the same
size as x--
we'll see that-- and integrate
it effectively backwards
in time, because I have
final condition on p--
if I do both of those things,
and I can write down u as being
the argument of
what's left-- h, x--
then I've satisfied a necessary
condition for optimality.
Let's try to make sense of that.
How many people have done
optimization before at all?
How many people have seen
Lagrange multipliers before?
OK, good-- so let me say a
few things but not dwell.
And there's a lot of
information in the notes--
as fast as I can type.
All right, in general,
what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to
minimize some function.
In this case, I'm
trying to minimize
J. I'm trying to
minimize this J of x
by finding the u [INAUDIBLE]
which minimizes then.
But let's make it
a little simpler
just to make sure we
get the basic idea.
Let me just say J is some
function of some parameter
alpha.
I'm trying to minimize J--
I can even do it even simpler.
Let's just say
minimize over x J of x.
So if I have some
function of x--
J of x looks like this--
I want to find the minimum.
The first condition,
the necessary condition,
is that, at the minimum,
the derivative of that thing
better be 0.
So I can check by just checking
if partial J, partial x equals
0, that I've got a necessary
condition for a minimum.
That's actually a lot of it.
The second part is the
Lagrange multiplier part.
Let's say x is a vector now--
a two-dimensional vector.
Let's say I want to
do the optimization
min J of x, subject to the
constraint that x1 equals x2--
or let's do something
slightly more interesting.
x1 plus x2 is 3.
Turns out, thanks to
the method of Lagrange--
one of his many methods--
solving this problem is no
more difficult than solving
this problem-- finding necessary
conditions for this problem.
By just making an
augmented function,
you can now minimize x and
lambda of J of x plus lambda
times this constraint--
which, in this case,
is x1 plus x2 minus 3--
has to equal 0.
It turns out, if partial
J, partial lambda equals 0,
then that means the
constraint is enforced.
Partial J, partial lambda in
this is x1 plus x2 minus 3.
If that equals 0, which
is the condition I'm
looking for anyways for the
minimum, then I've now--
not only have I satisfied my
constraint, but the remaining
minima--
the minimization of this is
this constrained solution
to that optimization.
The Lagrange multiplier
method is very, very useful.
If you don't know
it, look it up.
It's very good.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in the
partial J, partial lambda,
that J [INAUDIBLE]
partial is this new J--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, sorry.
Thank you.
Yep.
Good catch, good
catch-- thank you.
Partial of-- I don't
know-- that whole thing--
partial lambda-- thank
you-- good catch.
And in the method of
Lagrange multipliers,
lambda has an interpretation
of a constraint force.
What you're about to see
is that all I'm saying
in Pontryagin's
minimum principle--
which is an absolute
staple in optimal control--
is all I'm saying
is that J of x is--
which is my cost function--
my cost-to-go function--
is at a stationary point
with a Lagrange multiplier
which enforces this dynamic.
And that Lagrange
multiplier happens to p.
OK?
So let's just see
how that plays out.
OK, so this is a sketch
of the derivation
of Pontryagin's minimum
principle, which, I think--
I'm just going to
do enough so you
see where those
things are and have
some intuition about them--
a sketch of it based on
the calculus of variations.
So there's many
other ways to do it--
calculus of variations,
which is a scary name
for a very simple thing.
This is the problem solving--
J of x0 is h of x
plus integral over g,
subject to those constraints.
So how do I write that in
terms of a Lagrange multiplier?
I'm going to do a
second function, which
I won't make the mistake
of calling J again here.
Let's call it S. Some function
S is going to be h of xT
plus the integral from
0 to T of g of xt,
ut plus some Lagrange
multipliers--
p in this case--
times my constraint, which
is x dot minus f of xu.
I was trying to
use T's everywhere.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, so now I can explicitly
try to find the place where S--
which is my Lagrange multiplayer
version of my problem,
which has the explicit cost
that I'm trying to minimize--
subject to the constraints
that x better be--
satisfy my dynamics--
exactly the same
as that two-second Lagrange
multiplayer introduction.
Now, getting it right
is a little bit funny.
So S is now--
you could think of S as
a functional [INAUDIBLE]
a function of functions.
If I take a variation,
this is just--
it's going to be exactly
like your basic calculus,
but the calculus of
variations uses these symbols
for a variation on
a function is just
going to be partial h, partial
x times the variation in x
of T plus the integral 0 dt
Notice quickly that this
thing inside here is just h.
That's my Hamiltonian.
So that thing inside
there I can just--
OK, this says this is a
variational analysis of S that
says, if my function changes by
some small amount in x tilde,
this is the result of--
in changing S-- in S.
Similarly, if my thing
changes by a little bit in xt,
or in ut, or pt,
or in all of them
simultaneously, this tells
me what the variation's
going to be in S.
The stationary conditions
then-- if I'm at an optima,
what I care about is that--
if I change u a little bit,
if I change x a little bit,
if I change p a little
bit, S better not change.
That's my condition--
my necessary condition
for optimality.
If partial h, partial
p is 0, then I
know that changing p isn't
going to change the solution,
so I can look for stationary
points with respect to p.
Partial h, partial
p better be 0.
What's partial h, partial p?
Well, it turns out it's
just x dot minus f of xu,
which is my forward dynamics.
So if I've integrated my
system forward in time,
then this thing's
going to be true,
and [INAUDIBLE] steady state
with respect to changes in p.
OK, let's look at the
changes with respect to x.
So to get the contributions
from x correct,
we first need to worry
about this x dot.
We don't want to have that x
dot floating around in there,
so let's integrate by parts
to get that out of there.
We're going to look at
this partial h, partial x--
the variations-- but
first, integrate by parts.
The integral of my p of
t x dot t dt from 0 to t
is just going to be p
of T, x of T minus p0,
[? x0 ?] minus the integral
capital T of p dot t x of t--
I forgot my transpose--
dt-- basic integration by parts.
OK, if I now take my variation
in partial x, having used that,
then what I get is--
which gives me-- which, in
this case, was partial g,
partial x transpose plus partial
f, partial x transpose p of t.
My goal is to show you
enough of the derivation
that you understand
what these terms are,
and not so much to get
completely bogged down in it.
If you want a good treatment,
a careful treatment,
you should see Bertsekas
optimal control book.
When I say careful
treatment there,
it's going to be 5
pages or more at least.
OK, so Pontryagin's minimum
principle says that,
if my constraint is
satisfied to x dot,
and if I can just integrate back
to this p dot backwards in time
from some final conditions--
which are the same basic
variation argument
that drives this--
then I found Lagrange
multipliers which
satisfies that constraint.
And the final variation
says that u had better
be the minimum of h of x.
That puts me at
a local minima in
my constrained optimization--
big pill to swallow,
but this is the way
we're going to show that the
brick solution is optimal.
People are much
more enthusiastic
when there's bricks.
It's OK.
I understand.
OK, so let's turn the crank and
use this tool now to see what
the heck--
see if we can verify our
original bang-bang policy
is optimal.
So for the bang--
Pontryagin bang-bang
double integrator--
what's the [INAUDIBLE]
look like for this thing?
g of xu we said was just 1--
and p transpose times
x dot minus f of xu.
I'll just write it
out in elements forms.
It's so simple.
It's p1 times q dot
plus p2 times u.
OK?
If we had derived our bang-bang
controller just like this,
then we could actually
immediately say,
what's the optimal
control solution?
If I want to take u star as
the argmin, u in negative 1
of 1 of h x, u, p--
and what's it going to
be, just looking at what
I've got on the board here?
This is a good time to
make sure you get it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah-- good.
So these terms are--
have no impact.
If p2 is positive, and I
want to minimize this thing,
then u better be negative--
as negative as possible.
Negative as possible
means negative 1.
And if p2 is negative,
then you should
be as positive as possible
to minimize that thing.
So it turns out our same
policy that we worked hard
for in the Pontryagin, in terms
of the Lagrange multipliers,
works out to just be p2--
sine of p2 of t--
negative sine, sorry.
So the sine function is just
1 if it's greater than 0,
negative 1 if it's less than 0.
My equations for p--
which, if I didn't use the
word adjoint equations yet,
I should have--
these equations for p are
called the adjoint equations.
My equations for p
are pretty painless.
So p1 dot is negative
partial h, partial x1.
x1 is q, so--
doesn't appear at all.
That's 0.
So that Lagrange multiplier
isn't going to change at all.
That's pretty painless.
And p2 dot is negative
partial h, partial x2,
and that's negative p1 t.
OK, so it turns out that p1--
my Lagrange multiplier's just
going to be some constant.
And p2-- t is just going to be
the interval of that constant--
c2 plus c1 times t.
Try and debate how
much to squeeze
in the next few minutes--
you know what, let's--
let me do it tomorrow for
real-- or on Thursday for real,
because I don't-- because
it's going to take 10 minutes
to finish, but it's
worth doing it right.
So for homework, to yourself,
see if you can work it through.
Take the equations
that we had and show
that these-- those four
conditions are satisfied,
and I'll spend the first 10
minutes of class doing it
properly on Thursday.
I don't want to rush through
it and have it mean nothing.
Sorry.
I wrote 3 here.
There's a condition-- a
final condition on p2--
so three conditions
by this number.
Awesome.